need motivation watch a top 10 would
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself so get ready for some big brand
thinking advice from Grant Cardone to
give you the motivation confidence and
belief that you need
ok let's kick it off with rule number
one don't stay small first thing you got
to do is to set as a business owner do I
want to make more money see see if this
dude this dude with the camera if he
shot if it's if it's pockets are empty
he's walking around empty pockets and
he's got his fancy camera this is the
the problem with the artists they starve
their whole life they starve their
entire life and then and then you wonder
why they're grumpy there's no money I'm
eating it littles all the time sooner or
later sooner or later you hit the
reality he hits the reality I got a nice
camera
I love taking photos I got to shoot
Grant Cardone he watches Lord Sugar
leave on his jet and says hey why does
he get to fly free everywhere do
whatever he wants and I'm stuck with my
camera and no money how many believe
that sooner or later sooner or later
after days are going to work months are
going to work years ago into work sooner
or later if he works for this man he's
like I resent this man I resent this man
I resent that man business owner I
resent Paul McFadden the business owner
I resent you so I know I won't work for
you in fact what I'm gonna do is screw
things up for you it's called
disengagement the only business people
that were survived the only
entrepreneurs that will make it in
business are those people that decide to
grow their businesses little little will
fails not the little grocery store okay
if you try to stay small if you try to
stay small you will fail okay I'm
telling you this for personal experience
I tried to stay small I tried to manage
the business I tried to be the king of
the business I tried to have no
employees because employees cost money
I'm like I'm not going to have any
employees I'm not going to pay the
cameraman I'll just hire him when I do a
gig and the next time I'll hire another
guy and that'll keep my expenses low how
many were brought up like this
keep the expenses real low where we can
manage the expenses they're good the
expenses are going to be so small that
that no matter how much we make I keep
it all rule number two brand and
advertise you have to advertise you have
to advertise in your career to blow your
brand up you cannot not advertise and
save money cost me probably four hundred
should I even say a number this big or
do I lose everybody four hundred million
dollars we have estimated is what it
cost me because I didn't advertise for
the first 20 years of my career but
before you spend one dollar and
advertising and and even if it was
wasted it'd be a great dollar to spend
even if you don't get a return you
should do it
but before you do that what you need to
do is spend a lot of time energy and
resources on branding I made a mistake
here not spending more money in
advertising I made a bigger mistake not
spending more time energy and resources
on branding and you are making a mistake
if you do any kind of metrics on did it
convert did it pay off branding will not
pay off zero you will get a zero return
if you don't Brent okay you will get a
zero return for branding in the
beginning you will get you will never
get a return on advertising if you don't
bring branding is a must it is senior to
advertising rule number three work on
yourself you think we're not people that
are changing will not change you I know
this whole mastermind thing we have
masterminds I believe they're great
they're awesome but
Brian back there hangs around me and I'm
changing that don't mean he's gonna
change so look I've seen this for 30
years you know I've gone places where
the the only reason everybody went there
was because they were working on
themselves changing improving courses
classes education elena actually great
story about Elena and I the only reason
people went to these places was to
improve themselves okay I got to tell
you something only about ten percent of
the people that went there flew they
were changing they were actually making
the changes the other people were
hanging around people change
just cuz you're around people change it
doesn't mean you are gonna change you
got to do the work to change my brothers
and sisters you got to change you know
you know Ryan hangs around me if I
changed my clothes that don't mean he
changes his if everybody in the house
changes their clothes takes a shower put
some deodorant it don't mean if Ryan
does not change his clothes and take a
shower and put it on his deodorant he
gonna stank dropping bomb to change you
got to change it doesn't matter how many
people you hang around there to changing
if you if you hang around everybody just
getting rich getting wealthy doing great
creating stuff and you're not you're not
gonna change to change you got to change
rule number four don't listen to bad
advice I heard a man tell me once he's
like grant money won't make you happy
I'm like son so you ain't got any money
quit giving advice or something you've
failed that right if you take a notes
you want to write this down never ever
ever ever take advice from a quitter
never ever take advice from a quitter
particularly financial advice the first
question I asked you today was this do
you want to make more money then quit
taking advice from people about money
they don't have any money also if you
want to have more confidence and self
love check out my 250 for series they
are free the links to join are in the
description below I've been at a point
in my life where I thought I thought
less than me then anyone thought of me
how many have been there my dreams are
first every day then my wife
then my kids I could take care of my
wife and my kids now would you agree I
abandoned this this is the fuel for Who
I am you have to go build
self-confidence rule number 5 set big
goals this used to be a goal of mine to
make 1 million dollars a year that was
my goal when I was 35 years old one day
I said to myself one day I said self
little g donk
little g no one day young man I wrote
this over and over and over again I
talked to myself in the mirror I'd sit
on the toilet and say one day one day
I'm gonna I'm gonna make a million
dollars one day one day and people used
to tell me that's crazy dude like why do
you think so big this is when people
were telling me not to you're like what
do you need to do all that why do you
just be happy just be a good person okay
be happy that you live in America be
happy that you have meals and be happy
you've got good health and all the
things that the people around you that
quit on money that quit on financial
freedom that quit on possibility they
quit on their potential all the things
those people will tell you to try to
convince you to quit when in reality
what they're really trying to do is make
sense of why they quit note to self
okay last month I distributed 1.2
million dollars to other people okay
it's not money I made it's money I sent
out so it just goes to show you how
small I was thinking when I was 35 years
old rule number six go where the money
is
this is them at the Beverly Hills Hotel
today
if you never stayed here you have to
okay every single day that I have been
here I have met someone that will help
me in my career yes they don't tell you
this in school they don't teach you this
your parents didn't teach you this you
have to go where the money is money is
not just okay I'm gonna buy a
Lamborghini and I'ma buy a big house and
I'ma buy some jewelry and I'ma get some
nice sunglasses imma go find a big watch
and I'm gonna go on vacation it's about
going where other people are that have
money and that can help you that can
help you so you can help others so you
can help your parents so you can take
care for them so you can take care of
your kids so you could be a good example
look money's not gonna make you happy
you guys already know that everybody
knows that I don't even know what we're
talking about money will not make you
happy
it'll get you an uber it'll get you to
veranda get your hotel yeah it'll get
you access to the Polo Lounge it'll get
you breakfast this morning to sit at the
right place with the right people that
may be someone someone discovers what
you're doing what you're up to
and that takes interest every single
breakfast every single lunch that I've
been here in every single dinner that
I've been sitting up in public I have
met someone that can literally help me
with my career rule number seven keep
things simple do you want to make your
business bigger I know this seems really
simple but the reality is if it's not
simple I don't care where you are on
planet earth whether you're in Wales I'm
gonna go to Glasgow tomorrow we're gonna
leave here and go into Spain I'm gonna
do rush in about three months I'm gonna
go back to Miami and do business in
Miami no matter where in the world I am
folks if it's not simple you're not
gonna make money listen to what I'm
telling you if it's not simple you will
not make money over long periods of time
it's got to be simple for other people
to understand it
rule number eight invest guy invest
$5,000 he's got $5,000 in the bank
another guy's got 50 grand in the bank
and another guy's got $500,000 okay all
three of these people invested money
with me this is cliff this is Dave and
this is Jennifer
okay cliff sent me five grand dude it
was his last five grand it was as hard
for him to do this is this guy to do
that do you understand okay this guy
runs I don't know he's gonna earn 300
bucks a year this guy's gonna earn
$3,000 a year
this guy's gonna earn $30,000 a year but
they all had to start with this they all
start with $5,000 everybody starts to
$5,000 including Jennifer right here
she's got a 5 just in another 0 all of
them had to make a decision should I
keep the money this is where the
opportunity comes in you got to think in
terms of opportunity costs okay is my
money better in the bank or is my money
better in an ass
that ad that they can grow over time
okay do I buy a watch okay do I buy
something stupid it is beautiful but
it's stupid let's keep it real stupid is
as stupid does and that ladies and
gentlemen is stupid Patek okay however
the reason the way I bought the paddock
was because the real estate that I buy
not this real estate okay I already
distribute to these people the real
estate I invested in sent me a little
check check rule number nine reach your
full potential
how many heard this statement before
knowledge is power Warren Buffett was on
TV yesterday's 88 years old he's worth
eighty three billion dollars okay I want
to know where where the guy is in his
cycle
everybody's got a life cycle I'm young
I'm broke
I get a little bit of money on middle
class now okay now I'm rich now I'm
super wealthy okay and now I'm gonna die
my data points will change everybody
agree with that where are you getting
the data from okay yeah if this is
probably where I'm at right now in a
number of places in my life both my
finances my brand recognition my
international presence my business
expansion I'm probably up on a upward
slope I might be down here and not even
know it yet okay cuz I might not know
how I could go probably this is a
mistake I didn't know how big I could
get so down here what am I telling you
right then get you money safe like if
you go back and read my books when I was
thirty years old thirty five years old
done it save you money save all your
money save all your money why I'm trying
to put some money away then I then I get
right here I'm like I need to get the
money to work right I get here I'm like
I need to get the people around me
making money when I'm starting this
cycle so you need to understand when
you're listening to me today
leave here and you go to John Maxwell's
workshop where is John in the cycle of
his life the source of data Steve Jobs
Steve Jobs was down here animal he was
an animal him and Bill Gates were like
carnivorous they weren't thinking about
giving money away they didn't have any
money they were in a garage right
scrapping out and buying tacos probably
stealing a little bit warren buffett
warren buffett down here took 500 shares
of Ford Motor Company stock for free to
pitch it to tell people I have 500 years
of the IPO in 1957 Ford Motor Company
went public
he got 500 shares from the company to
say he was behind Ford Motor Company he
didn't buy Ford Motor Company they gave
him this chairs it's a it's against the
law okay he's outside the statute of
limitations that's what he did then
that's not what he's doing now and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is committing raise
your hand if you've ever given up before
giving up and quitting are very
different things
one you never try again the other you
might toss them if you refuse to give up
I promise you you will have a victory
and when you do you gotta get a sweet
victory day most people are getting just
enough to compare themselves to be
better off than other people if you have
desire in your heart if you want to do
better you have to put your money your
energy where your commitment is now I've
got a special bonus tip from Grant on
how to get money that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that is time for
the three-point landing questions let's
go from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
what is your big goal number two how are
you going to stop staying small and
number three how can you go where the
money is I don't want to talk to you
about execution and management and
business planning and culture I want to
talk to you about money because money we
believe is the number one problem in
your business it's not mission it's not
purpose it's not all these beautiful
things everybody tells you it's not
planning and organizing I have seven
businesses there's seven little
companies there's been no plant there's
been minimal organizing tremendous speed
it's tremendous speed to market okay
it's one of the things that has made us
successful but mostly in all the
businesses every business was created
around the concept it needs to make
money
[Music]
cuz if it doesn't make money
you'll call yourself an entrepreneur
[Music]
because you're not gonna able to call
yourself a businessperson and so this
industry of entrepreneurs that that is
now so popular I never even knew the
term until like a year and a half ago
okay before that I was in California
somebody said I was an entrepreneur
fifteen years ago I'm like well that's
that's code for I don't have a job okay
today today look if you want to be an
entrepreneur good but really what you
want to do is evolve to being a
businessperson that makes money and that
provides a good living for a lot of
other people right so number one problem
in your business is employee
disengagement it is not actually money
money is their problem employee
disengagement how many of you here own a
runner Department let me see if you run
or manage more than more than just
yourself let me see him how many of you
here run or manage a household okay good
well if you can't manage the household
by the way you have disengagement at a
household level would you agree husband
and wife are disengaged one's doing
their own plan this one's doing their
plan 50% of those marriages are gonna
fail okay that's what they say they're
gonna divorce truth is way more than 50%
fail people should not be looking at the
divorce rate they should be looking at
the failure rate
if you want more grant cardone and check
out the top 50 rules of video I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there if you're
not going to work like a 10-hour day as
a short day for me I hear more people
promoting this for our idea